welcome to this video playing richie
from Colombia Colombia I got a I guess
the flag right ok so he's playing the
four pound attack against the other hand
this is not good news I really i only
played this and blitz chess when when
i'm close to mouth sleeping have no idea
about the opening i hope that this g6 i
actually saw this and i'm in a team
match recently well the team made of
mine played this I'm just trying to open
up as quickly as possible mmm yeah I was
thinking 97a you but
can take him it's probably not enough
and galaxies five letters to proclaim
they thought night 67 but he can really
take on the sixth bit stupid okay maybe
I can make it gambit all of this with f6
something
I'm not too too bad in development so at
least this is quite okay here
now I need to open the position up we
takes i attack with the bomb play rookie
a jeweled eh maybe maybe there is a bit
of compensation you happen but the way
exactly yeah the bishop on g7 dr.
playing at five may may provide with a
bit of compensation but so not exactly
great Knight f6 gphone i def 64 this is
sodium can try to play for
hmm
not sure about that really hmm how to
continue the sistas maybe so I'm
interesting if I get get some pressure
on the line they will take only six
anyway pro Knight f3 Bishop e3 can play
them yeah yeah yeah I know all right
check
can just move the king unfortunately
King g1 or something and why does an
excellent shape yep when threatening
notes is seven unfortunately maybe maybe
if I get to play night before this is
something right before a to attacking a
20 aha maybe this is something with the
night here okay Leah's check and get the
check is annoying some way to avoid that
Knight c3 yeah I don't just check
playbook see aid it doesn't give the
check it doesn't even give the check
okay after this is a safe form
slightly we get this move I don't know
let's let's do this
I don't know this is this night
attacking a to all the time I've heard
rookie one coming okay maybe Brooke you
won't even rook e1 f1 something
they cannot play see 6m so 94 maybe I
can tempt him look at some how to do it
he's doing it okay rook f1 even better
on just take it I have g4 check check
check chief forward check kingi tune I
don't see and don't see it at the moment
how to how to meet him as they're made I
can take here take a tool why do I
overlooked a medium I mean it looks like
a maid okay come on this should be
enough William Jay Jay how to win though
this one can give a cup of checks and
takes you soon with 20 seconds on the
clock
oh yeah probably should have just taken
the draw him yeah check
yeah this this was rather quick chek
time learning check check check check
ah i can take not yet yeah what the crap
game yes uh yeah okay I resigned thanks
uh what the nonsense game yeah where's
couple of chicks Jack Jack Jim why at 16
seconds it was probably a very very bad
shape at some point anyway and then it
was here him here there must be a major
or whatever yeah minus five i didn't i
didn't see it I simply didn't see it
this is the winner you know ok cannot
play now rookie two and then this one
what no root d8 yeah would be eight I
know okay d tools was hanging was check
I see it's always a check and this is
too much yeah they were there needed to
be a winner in he really am lost the
thread there after being a completely
winning before around here white is just
winning of course ah what a game thanks
for watching